political correspondent ed O'Keefe flew
overnight from Iowa to New Hampshire
through a cloud of uncertainty I expect
edge people to judge you heard just
talked about to us about his campaigns
estimate from waiawa he says he's the
winner does he have reason to be
confident do you think no not
necessarily Anthony and frankly for a
candidate who has talked about his
concerns with the misinformation that
the president has spread and someone who
has campaigned on his belief in science
and facts to be spreading incomplete
facts this morning is pretty astounding
but he needs to do that because he'd
like to come into this state with a big
head of steam and try to prevail going
into Tuesday but let's take a look for
example at some of the data that his
campaign is sharing the numbers from his
team unverified by Iowa Democrats and
CBS News say he captured 28% of the
state's delegates from three-quarters of
the reporting precincts oh that's only
75 percent of the potential data he
isn't the only candidate declaring
victory or some kind of victory right
now senator Bernie Sanders his team last
night put out their own numbers from
nearly 40 percent of caucus precincts
even fewer locations indicating that he
was in the lead and boo digit was in
second place again those numbers are
unverified by the Democratic Party of
Iowa and CBS News without any real
answers in Iowa presidential hopefuls
are now here in New Hampshire trying to
find some sense of momentum and
realizing that any moment and they could
have gotten from a definitive victory
right last night at least is gone for
now as one aide to one of the campaign's
told me after we all landed here in New
Hampshire this morning quote this
deflates any potential momentum for any
candidate remember the State of the
Union is tonight the impeachment vote is
tomorrow there's a new debate Friday
night that could reset the race entirely
and everybody should just throw out New
Hampshire and focus or throw out Iowa
and focus here on New Hampshire that's
the words of one senior aide to one of
these campaigns that's a pretty
astounding statement to throw out Iowa
and New Hampshire is a week away so what
are the candidates doing to get ready
well there are dozens of events across
New Hampshire today as these candidates
head the diners and community centers
and will be meeting with voters across
the state most candidates landed here
directly from Iowa earlier this morning
including senator Amy Klobuchar Andrew
yang and senator Elizabeth Warren Warren
told CBS News quote when I left I oh I
said it's too close to call and it still
is but I feel good unquote but not all
the candidates are as optimistic we're
expecting former Vice President Joe
Biden's team especially to raise major
concerns later today if when the caucus
results are released if the state
Democratic Party doesn't produce a paper
trail for all roughly 1700 precincts in
the state we can expect his lawyers will
go to court it'll be a two-pronged
battle a legal battle certainly to
figure out what went wrong but also a PR
or expectations battle because remember
in the closing days of this campaign in
Iowa it looked as if Biden wasn't going
to do that well so he'd like to sort of
diminish or raise concerns about those
results as much as possible to give him
potentially a better showing here in New
Hampshire and sent him off into Nevada
in South Carolina meanwhile some
Republicans are already seizing on last
night's caucus mishap it's a mock
Democrats take for example with Donald
Trump jr. tweeted quote everyone's
really excited about the prospect of
turning over our entire health care
system to you guys he said about
Democrats arguing that if they can't
even get an election done how could they
run the country yeah yep it seems the
jokes are gonna start writing themselves
thank you very much
you